bình bảo, những bình trứng vi hiện mà cập cúm gây ra.
Càng cúm, một căn bệnh thình xin xây ra,
khiết lại trong khi thời tiết sống ngọt chuyển ngọng lại thất thương,
bệnh càng cúm sẽ nhận lẫn với thằng lại,
khi nhiều người chủ quan, nhưng để lâu sẽ khai ra nhiều bình trứng cúm quyền vi hiện.
Một film phổi, khuống là tăng nhận chủ vô gây ra viên phổi,
trong thời kính bệnh trở nặng, khai viên vi hiện tới tiếng mạc.
Phuyên phổi cần điều phát hiện và điều chỉ sớm để tránh những hộ của hình trong.
2, bên đề bệ tai mũ học,
thầm cùng film giải gây ra tình trạng xuất cao li đục,
khi hông nặng nhất lời chế em,
nhưng không chết chính rất nhiều,
trên nhỏ sẽ bị viên tai dưới,
thủ măng nhí,
quyền trên chính giản thình giáo sau này.
3, hình xin nặng.
Mạng đang có bệnh đi nền là hình xin,
khi hay thật cần thật,
vì cảm khuống sẽ khiến xu phê của bạn cho liền tổ tế hòa rất nhiều.
Tình trạng khó thật gây,
khiến người bệnh thương ước,
mề mòa và rất nệ gạm với các chất cây kích ứng.
Bốn có sật,
chế em là đối thượng để bị có sật khi cảm khuống,
tình trạng xuất cao liền tục không các cơm gây hại cho bế đàn hử lớn tối xúc hẹn.
5, đêm xong,
khi bị cảm khuống,
trong khuống xong có nhiều chất ngay chưa bị khoản,
biểu,
lâu dành gây nhiễm trung và giận diễn điếp xong.
Sao, hội chứng rai,
đây là một biên trường vi hệm nhất của bạn khuống,
nó kinh ra và nạo xin dấy,
hội chứng ngay rất đi thập,
nhưng nhiều khuống máy mốt phải,
lại vô khuống nghiêm trọng về xúc hẹn người bạn.
Khuống sẽ chảy ra thêm lo.
Bây bạn nên chú ý thật hiện,
cũng có đề đủ cho tình dưới.
Vuyện tập hẹn thao tình dưới,
để rửi chiến suất hẹn tôn nhất cho có thể.
Chúc bạn và sạm đi ngôi thích khoản mạnh.